Chanakya mara is preparing to open his
toy store in con market for the first
time in nearly two months it's in one of
the most expensive parts of the Indian
capital with the highest rent our sales
are zero now and the government is
saying we have to take the salary
payments we have to make sales as you
know the rentals are so high in con
market we cannot survive making the
shops closing the Indian government
announced on Sunday night that all
markets are allowed to open but it's for
states to decide the rules con market is
one of New Delhi's well known and
usually busiest while shop selling
essential items have remained open most
of its 150 stores bars and restaurants
have been closed for the past eight
weeks at an estimated cost of nearly
forty million dollars from Tuesday shops
in Delhi's markets must take turns
opening on alternate days to keep the
number of Market goers down the
president of the car market traders
Association says while a shop owners
want their businesses to function seven
days a week the pandemic isn't far from
everyone's mind because of the economy
we we were happy that we are coming back
into the walk now and but as far as over
health is concerned we are a little
concerned about it because we need to
make the people understand what actually
means to come to a market the Indian
government has allowed the easing of
restrictions in certain areas despite
the number of cases reaching nearly
100,000 Delhi's Chief Minister says the
government has used the past eight weeks
to prepare the healthcare system for any
rise in the number of cases as more
activities are allowed we have to learn
to live with Corona Corona will be there
and our lives will keep going we can't
have a permanent lockdown elsewhere in
the country barber shops and salons have
also opened and the government announced
that people will be allowed to travel in
private vehicles and buses between
states that agree to the move the latest
easing of restrictions has led to
traffic on the roads for the first time
in months but while many people are now
able to move around outside the
situation remains the same for India's
millions
migrant workers who've been stranded and
are still waiting at transport hubs
trying to get home
Elizabeth / Adam al-jazeera New Delhi